[Music]
probably the most unbelievable part of
this episode is that june hoe follows
the van this closely on deserted roads
and isn't considered suspicious by the
van driver
and that's all i can really say about
that because my phone has auto don't
ruin the plot correct character checks
to see if their gun accidentally
unloaded itself not because they really
need to but because the audience needs
to know they have a gun cliche sure
because sliding beneath a van and
dragging yourself along the road is
super easy to do
[Music]
hey did you hear that
yeah that's the sins bam squid game uses
red text and includes the same bam we
use in our intros and now i can only
assume that the show is taunting us as a
way to make sure we send them so just
remember that anything you don't like
about this video is really the creator's
fault we're just doing their bidding at
this point there are literally drivers
in every vehicle and guards posted for
this very reason and no one sees this so
red suit guy scans the passengers in the
van that he has been driving without
giving a second thought to the reality
of having an additional person in the
back we're not even five minutes in and
we're already dealing with the golden
corral of convenient obliviousness
buffets none of the highly trained
individuals on this ship notice one van
violently shaking back and forth i
should probably just stop mentioning all
the ways people in the show seem to miss
the obvious here's five thousand sin won
for any more instances jung ho changed
this guy's clothes then goes the extra
mile to tuck his shirt into his pants
and buckle his belt before chucking him
off the boat just chuck him off the boat
and stop wasting time murder and yes i
know there's a lot of that on this show
but i think he's supposed to be one of
the good guys for a well-funded
well-guarded death festival this place
sure does have lack security you know
these people are coming back and you
can't invest in a few metal detectors
this very obvious heartbeat in the neck
a lot of people decided to come back so
there you go 187 of the 201 people
decided to come back to murder game
central because when a large group of
people see 56 percent of their
companions get executed right in front
of their eyes 93 percent of them are
like yeah let's go back to that place
think she named
a kid yet why would anyone name their
kid yet you're right who knows what game
they'll have us play next yeah it's not
like they're gonna paint it on the walls
for you come on let me join you guys
geez we're spending the first 15 minutes
of this episode on what teammate
selection just get to the squid gaming
already and satiate our desire for
violence and hypocritical need to sin
you for it
how about it
plenty of empty bits emptying stubborn
ketchup bottles on empty beds keep an
eye on the ones who didn't return to
play
and keep me posted me too can i be kept
posted too that sounds like a really
interesting idea and now that you've
drawn attention to it i'm sure the show
will explore it more this season this
may look efficient to you but after 409
gets his foodie crosses in front of 417
which stops the flow of traffic this is
not the vision i wish the rice was
piping hot that's racist and for girls
there's congee elastics cat's cradle
whoa oh there buddy how dare you gender
cat's cradle how pinky pull your tractor
face so fast you can't even handle my
string theory son this flapping gum
noodle you may be wondering how anyone
would be suspicious of june ho in his
mask costume but some people are
observant enough to notice that their
neighbor is shorter fatter or using a
different dominant hand all things that
could really blow juno's cover you know
aside from having no clue about the pink
suits patterns of walking and movement
hey hey hey open the door you jerks i
have to pee really bad right now this
sentence for having to watch player 212
scratch the door like a cat in heat for
60 seconds so she can have a [ __ ]
potty break also how do they not have a
bathroom open at night in the common
area for the love of prostates are none
of the players over 40. i think i'll go
pee right here and now here i go
you all ready to hear some rain your
intimidation tactics of all the
contraband to slip into the game this is
what you choose to stuff in a container
and pop into your crotch pocket why not
a taser or a knife or don't go back and
smoke whenever you want
are you going to go in there i want to
see what's up there how are these two
not being supervised setting aside that
the powers of the bee could certainly
find a female guard it's not exactly
like this place is heavy on the privacy
protocol hey guys make sure you clear
the slaughtered bodies from the floor
and incinerate them oh and strip change
all the players while they're
unconscious but don't you dare be in the
same room as a woman while she pees we
might get sued perpetuating the lie that
an air duct will support a human's body
weight this hurts a lot it's like trying
to push out a kid
honest question is she trying to keep
the guard out or get them in here to
check on her because going this far over
the top seems like the latter is the
more likely option
[Music]
i mean this in the nicest way possible
but if 212 doesn't die in this episode i
can't keep watching i just can't the
island
abductions
surveillance
and the masks oh oh things also included
in the show lost please wake up and
prepare for your duties kind wake up
notifications if you want me out of my
warmth cocoon you're gonna have to treat
me like the lazy no good nick i truly am
say something like either get up or i'll
strip your blanket off and squirt you
with this water gun while farting in
your face you know like a good mom would
are you saying they were melting sugar
in there i think they were i know this
clue obviously leads someone to figure
out the next game but why would you
think this was anything more than some
sort of jello or something they were
making for the next meal why is everyone
so sure this is a game clue when if i'd
spotted it i've been like damn it i
found the kitchen but where's the game
closet any chocolate milk i can't drink
the normal kind asking your death camp
counselor for special treatment i'm also
explaining your digestive history to a
stranger as a kid i'm willing to bet you
got spanked a lot
how did you know spanking your children
for being lactose intolerant in other
words parents all the games they've made
us play in here are games that i've
known since i was a young boy and by all
the games do you mean the single game
you've played your theory is fine but
why would you say it this way unless
it's a mistranslation of the dub in
which case i'm more than happy to assign
this end to that nonsense instead you
know as a dubstep of precaution why the
hell is this playground so huge i think
it's meant to be a clever way to make
you feel like a kid again but i'm pretty
sure they overshot it by about 15 cause
honestly you'd have to be an infant to
be that much smaller than the slide we
can all agree on that right no fine i'll
do the math that slide appears to be a
little over three times as tall as these
guys and the average male height is
about five nine so that slide would be
right around 17 feet three inches tall
the average seven year old height is
around four feet and the tallest
playground slides are about 10 feet or
about 2.5 the size of the average 7 year
old which means this slide should be 2.5
times higher than the average 5.9 guy or
around 14 4 which is about 35 inches
shorter than this slide and 35 inches
over 17 3 which is 207 inches means that
this slide should be 16.9 percent
shorter than it currently is boom math
so here's a cinwon for the playground
equipment being too large a sinhon for
math in general a sinhon for not
believing me and a sinwon for all the
time you wasted making me do this once
you've chosen your shape please stand in
front of it
the shapes yes yes that is what she
meant should we play this together that
could be dangerous i know we're setting
up songwood to be a selfish [ __ ] in
this thing but what advantage does he
get by sending his friends and teammates
to more difficult shapes on pure
self-interest alone doesn't it make the
most sense for him to keep them around
at this point he doesn't even have to
let them know he knows what the game is
he can simply answer this question with
a sure let's all be on the same team and
then lead them to the triangle or circle
for some made up reason maybe like he's
a fan of the netflix reality show the
circle or something synergy songwoo it's
called synergy
[Music]
sugar honeycombs is not a game sugar
honeycombs is a breakfast cereal america
where did all these extra crumbles come
from
one of my channels how nice that the
first player who breaks their honeycomb
shape just happens to be on the slide
and in perfect position to take a
dramatic tumble down it what a cinematic
stroke of good fortune also we've now
entered the multiple point blank gun
murder portion of the episode look i
like this show but sometimes i don't
like that i like this show i suppose
cheating by using your vagina lighter as
its own sin but the bigger sin is how do
people keep getting away with this stuff
when there are guards everywhere
number 29. wait is he scanning the suit
we know junhoe hasn't had a chip
installed so are the chips in the suit
that's a terrible idea you know some of
these discount minions are getting
freaky at night and accidentally
swapping suits i hear those triangle
faces are into all sorts of nasty
shenanigans right
i can melt it from the back
the outline is thinner so it'll melt
first yes i know you literally just
showed us that through the actions of
the character you know like you were
supposed to and then you ruined it by
not trusting your audience enough and
over expositioning us we're dumb just
not quite that dumb taking this long to
discover the joys of cookie lingus
well i wanted to send all this close-up
licking so i wondered if there was a
word that better described close-up of
licking so i [ __ ] googled close-up of
licking damn it
[Laughter]
is this show seriously saying that this
tiny needle somehow penetrated that mask
and with enough pinpoint accurate
placement that it's actually in the
guard's eye this needle is barely even
in the mask and that mask is an inch
away from his eyes at least this needle
is an inch away from barely scratching
this guard's cheek at best and i can't
believe the show went with needle attack
for the guard takedown over just
tackling him and grabbing the gun what
kind of sick game was that what sort of
question is this you're literally
playing a game designed to kill people
once again even though i said i'd stop
bringing it up i can't help but say
no one sees this
[Music]
they can't
you wouldn't happen to have a cup of
warm water would you
if you want my mercy
shut that hole in the middle of your
face and listen
don't think i'll go pee right here and
now
if anyone's gonna piss on him it's gonna
be me
in prison dinner was always a big thing
we had a pasta course and then we had a
meal or fish
come on to the coast we get together
have a few laughs
the mucus
coating the intestinal wall
spasm
spasm
[Music]
number 29
player sir what's your duty today it's
my duty to please that booty